i gotta say andy uh i get excited i know
you do around the holiday season
and uh love it yeah i just love it what
do you think of our
our cutouts our audience member cut outs
from fans uh it's got the nice holiday
spirit doesn't it yeah well we
we've had a couple days to get used to
the hats but i think we could go a
little further with the holiday spirit
what do you mean go this seems like this
is a lot of work to put hats on
all these audience members yeah you mean
go further
let me show you um
hit it boys yeah see
they're getting flocked wow look at that
yeah look at there we go don't forget
comey
he gets the most
nice isn't this nice and festive it's
fantastic
yeah i mean you know it's like we live
in la but it's good to have the snow
you know
it's not sticking real well it's not a
sticky kind of snow you know but uh
it's not bad oh it's pretty good yeah if
you do this
it's like a winter wonderland
andy i'm really impressed we were able
to find this uh great fake snow
uh it's not technically fake snow it
just works like it you know
uh what is it something called asbestos
oh where'd you get it uh they're tearing
down this factory by
my house and they had a bunch of it so
it's very itchy though
yeah wow hurts when you breathe yeah
i hear that stuff's fine well merry
christmas
okay get flocked fantastic good job andy